[Music]
what is the craziest way
you've been woken up okay well you wake
me up
or used to it by my [ __ ] dad so so my
dad in high school i used to ditch all
the [ __ ] time right
and then you know they have those phone
calls like oh your sin didn't come to
school again
on those answering machines so my dad
will come back home from work at 2 am
listens to the answering machine what
the hell
and then he goes upstairs and because he
because i was bigger than him yeah
before i was like bigger than him
already like
he doesn't want to like come face to
face or whatever and also i'm in like my
angry teenage
phase you know so you just come and
punch me in the stomach and then go back
downstairs what the hell oh
so i'm waking up like power like a
little [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
and then i hear from downstairs you
didn't go to school wow
i woke up choking choking someone
choking you no
i woke up i don't know how but i was
i couldn't breathe i was choking and
then um this is when i lived with can
and uh he was his room was across from
mine so um i was coughing and my [ __ ]
face was going purple and [ __ ] and i was
crawling out oh my gosh
and he was high as balls dude
like this holy [ __ ] what do i do yeah
and then he grabbed an inhaler and he
came and he just threw it at me and i
just went
and i went ah
dude never heard the story yeah but like
did you find out what happened
what i have no idea yeah it's it just
i don't know what i was choking on i
don't know maybe if it was just
sleep apnea or whatever but i woke up
and i couldn't breathe and i was
coughing and i was like what the [ __ ]
and my veins were popping and [ __ ] whoa
who had an inhaler whose inhaler was
that can
throw it to him it was a nas bottle yeah
actually the the scariest way i got
woken up
for it was by three cops all right
right okay it was this one time similar
situation as yours where i didn't go to
school so i woke up in the morning i was
supposed to go
get a ride from a neighbor she ended up
leaving without me so then i came back
back home and i was like hey mom can you
take me to school she's like no take the
bus
and i'm like fine then you're not gonna
take me to school and i'm not gonna go
to school and i was a [ __ ] brat
yeah so then i end up going back to bed
and then i wake up with three cops in
the room
flashing their their flashlights in my
face and they're like wake the [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] loser go to [ __ ] school
what the [ __ ]
how did they get it damn oh because my
mom called the cops oh
that was tired yeah my mom called the
cops to like
stare straight yeah going to school and
i was like
what the [ __ ] but that was like the most
like startling
that is pretty scary jesus yeah i'll
wake up damn
what the [ __ ] yeah they were just
cussing and i was just like i'm just a
little girl
please where's the mcgruff guy dude [ __ ]
the cops
he's way i'll talk to him he's way
cooler i was on an airplane
and it was uh we're flying back from
guadalajara mexico
my city really that's where my family's
from i don't know what shout outs
gdl gdp
airport so we uh out cornered somebody
and the fight finished around like
midnight so we had to be
we got to the air the airport at like 3
a.m so we didn't sleep at all
i'm on the airplane 6am and i'm i'm
finally about to fall asleep so i
finally fall asleep
i'm asleep and i just wake up and
somebody spilled hot coffee all over me
oh
the person next to me so i wake up like
like freaking the [ __ ] out
was it really hot it was so hot oh [ __ ]
my stomach was burned and my pants were
just soaked for the rest of the flight
and it was like it was a three hour
flight who spilled at the past
the lady sitting next to me damn bro
no she felt really bad but i just was so
pissed [ __ ] yeah because i bro i didn't
sleep at all and i was so tired oh no
and my pant my underwear was all soaked
it smelled like coffee did it burn your
balls or anything
i burned my stomach whatever
smell of coffee whatever but dude i i
just was
spazzing out dude and i was so pissed
and we had two more hours left in a
flight and
we were like this i got bit my mosquito
it was awful [ __ ] crazy that your
story is
that because the story of this article
is something similar to that
all right so you got bit by a mosquito
the airplane yeah so imagine you're on
an airplane everyone close your eyes
you're on an airplane oh i love it i
trust the shoes i can't close my eyes
just
enjoyed a a fantastic getaway
weekend in vegas ah i like it you're
flying back home
so it's only gonna be 45 minutes long oh
you're flying back home to detroit
oh all right so i don't know how long
that is from one casino to another
all right and then uh you're you're
taking a red-eye trip all right so it's
you know everyone's asleep it's really
really quiet
you're like just had a great trip going
back home everything's nice
one how wonderful and then you start
feeling this warm sensation just
kind of come over pleasant over your
shoulder oh no did someone pee
over your shoulder all right it's warm
at first and then you realize
it's wet all right and you're kind of
like what the [ __ ]
you wake up and grogginess and
everything
you look over and the first thing you
see is the dick
what oh how does that even what do you
do
touch it [ __ ] i punch it touch it
punch it i mean punch it kiss it
nick you'd kiss it yeah something like
that suck it yeah
okay oh so this is the first time urine
coming out of it you just yes you smell
it
a girl named alicia beverly from detroit
she was coming going home today how do
you even get a dick that far
up you gotta like stand well maybe she's
like reclining a little bit
maybe the guy was really tall i don't
know so anyway i think he's tall
and drunk what if maybe he's hot dude so
she's
sleeping and she wakes up to someone
peeing the first thing she sees is a
dick
she realizes she's being pissed oh my
god she screams
wakes up the entire airplane i would too
[ __ ] turn their heads like what the
[ __ ]
and then what she sees is a man standing
over her
pissing on her doesn't say a single word
the entire
in front of her or behind her is he
sleepwalking in the side he's pissing
on him i feel like his eyes are closed
because he's just drunk and he's just
like
oh yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing
great point about the whole bathroom
thing
she's in the very very last row of the
airplane
next to the basket so she's on the
island oh i'll see yeah
so it wasn't a sexual thing okay was he
drunk was
i've he sleepwalking the story that what
what was it the pilot
let me find her real quick uh what's
been filed is
that um [ __ ] where to go where to go
where to go
are we saying he's drunk i am saying i
feel like you guys are saying he's drunk
okay so we don't know if he's drunk or
not uh he is
where'd he go i've been so drunk i
pissed in the trash can
same i woke up in the middle of the
night and then i thought the bathroom
was my trash can or a stall and then i
just pulled down my pants and peed in
the middle of my bedroom
i peed with my pants on in the trash can
you sat on it and peed yes i peed in a
trash can
and i was sober all right you're sober
that's even worse i was drunk
i remember from the video i saw all
right so what's been officially filed
in the report is that the pastor had an
apparent reaction pastor
did we know this wait what i didn't tell
you so so the man that was pissing
happened to be a very well-known pastor
a well-known pastor well-known pastor
from north carolina
jesus christ dude end route from from
las vegas to detroit i'd go figure i
don't know what's going on there
but yeah he had an apparent reaction to
the sleeping aid and
he wasn't right in the mind for whatever
was he on ambien
that she [ __ ] you up that [ __ ] makes
people do some crazy what is ambien
ambient is a sleeping medicine okay yeah
and it's really powerful and it
makes people kind of like sleep walk so
they're aware but they're like just
doing crazy [ __ ] didn't what's her name
yeah yeah yeah roseanne tweeted out
racist [ __ ] and she got her entire show
cancelled [ __ ]
she got removed from her own show that's
a good excuse i've sleep texted
on amp ambient no no no like um i i kind
of know what that's like
because i've basically woken up at like
five
and then just force a habit looking at
my phone and i'm like i'm typing right
and then later on um i'm reading my
responses
in this conversation and i'm like when
did i say this
why is it so crazy and i'm looking at it
i didn't i wasn't up at five in the
morning
damn and i was like did i get hacked i'm
like no no i actually i looked at my
phones when i picked it up yeah i did
pick up my phone
and then i remember oh [ __ ] maybe during
the time when i picked up my phone i
actually started responding to people
what if you were talking in your
sleeping like hey siri tell her to
go to hell no but it was it was it was
it was literally sleep typing because it
didn't make sense
oh but it kind of it just didn't make
any sense it autocorrected the best it
could and then it just
kind of pieced it that's wild yeah for
this guy he decided
to go take a piss on someone and uh
the girl started screaming luckily there
was a off-duty
police officer on flight and he ran over
apprehended the man the pastor and uh so
for the next four hours
uh the girl is sitting there wet
with covered and pissed not coughing
versus mine was obviously
that's what the flight wasn't four hours
it was at the beginning it was in the
beginning
nope i choose piss every time dude
really
that's a long time i don't know if it's
four hours i actually just saw four
hours here and it says since then i've
only gotten four hours of sleep this is
she's just talking about her dude poor
girl that is
the aftermath yeah so she's got really
high anxiety now
and uh she's just kind of got her world
rock she's never getting the aisle seat
ever again
no never again i love aisle seats now
too because you can just get up and go
which one would you prefer out of these
two evils
it's this situation getting pissed on
weight getting woken up
with piss all over you or the other
situation
woman the woman no no the woman that was
walking down the street i think it was
here in l.a
and then oh the dookie diarrhea soup
a homeless man had a bucket full of his
his
[ __ ] that he had been saving for a while
and then he dumped it save you for a
rainy day he said it was warm too right
take the piss like fresh diary i get
peed on
all day i would take you i wouldn't eat
all day bro holy
piss fresh pasta piss all day how about
this
how about this demonic [ __ ] how about
this for the guys for the guys
dookie from the hottest chick in the
world yes
from a nasty dude what's the what's her
diet like
i don't know that's true yo
she's a model she's eating good though
right like she constipated or does she
have diarrhea
that matters i gotta say p p is always
better than poo
it is even if it's from a dude yeah it
doesn't matter it stinks like poop just
stays
i don't can't swing in any other way
smell of poop makes me want to vomit
yeah because your health is sensitive to
smell you guys ever taken a [ __ ] and not
have water
like for your [ __ ] to land in like if
you're shooting oh yeah yeah
outdoors yeah yeah that's when you
really smell what your [ __ ]
smells like there was a guy that we used
to train with and uh he was
he was in prison for a while and he
would tell us like when you would take a
[ __ ]
in your cell people would get mad at you
like hey throw some water on that [ __ ]
dog like it smells terrible like they
would yell at you for
not maybe that's what the p's for you
know when you poo you always pee
yeah so nature maybe it's supposed to
poo and you're supposed to peel over it
that's that's exactly what it is don't
you usually pee before you poop
i've never pulled yeah but you might i
don't know that's why i like um let's
look into it guys
garbage dumps have misters that spray
water uh mist all over it to contain the
uh dust smell the smell particles
because the water will absorb the smell
particles have you ever [ __ ] in the
woods because i had
yeah one video oh no it's not a video
it's just a photo
oh we got a slideshow and a photo of uh
she probably got residual pee yeah a
little she got some splatters yeah yeah
exactly
well i'm hoping that wasn't after her
pee
where they took a selfie i'm i think
that was just got peed on
let's take a picture this is them in
good spirits
yeah that's before little did they know
after this photo what was going to go
down
terrible ordeal so yeah so uh dude if
you want to know what's happening with
the pastor
uh he's still in custody and uh
anything that happens in the sky the fbi
handles so
now yeah it's in the hands of the air
marshal yeah air marshal
that's crazy yeah i kind of feel bad for
the pastor crimes are worse in the air
because he wasn't being a pervert
he was just like he woke up like oh no
it's like a comedy show what if he's a
really good actor though you know it's
like
you can't you don't know intent right
yeah true who knows you could be a creep
like the lit like the other lady some
people get off on that i don't
know if someone would actually pee on
someone
just for her i'm sure somebody there's
everybody out there
no no no what i meant by that is like
how would you do this and think you
could get away with it yeah
i'm not on a flight there's nowhere to
go unless you're extremely dumb
maybe that's part of it you know
you